Dark Souls 3 is a game of valleys and
Peaks down through dungeons and up over
castle walls
it's a plummet into places we shouldn't
be and escape from places we don't
belong but of course we fight our way
through and find our way out there are a
few stumbles during the ascent but in
the end Dark Souls 3 is well worth the
riveting climb
this is the third in a series of dark
fence and role-playing games known for
their brutal difficulty in unforgiving
nature it grants minimal direction and
little room for error as with its
predecessors playing Dark Souls 3 means
accepting to extremes
recurring defeat and the reward of
breaking through it this is a game that
recognizes the value of perseverance
tearing you down before it pulls you
back up reinforcing the spots where it
broke you preparing you for the next
Valley down the road the world itself is
a disconnected series of detailed areas
some sprawl outward while others stack
on top of themselves folding back and
looping around in intricate webs it's a
testament to the impeccable level design
that discovering a bonfire checkpoint is
as important as leveling your character
or defeating a challenging boss in this
dangerous world of swamps prisons and
undead villages every milestone is a
victory it's also impressive how Dark
Souls 3 strikes a balance between
exploration and guidance there's usually
more than one path you can take through
the world at any time to new bosses
secret dungeons or new areas entirely
but never too many that it feels
overwhelming
the level design encourages wandering
without losing focus
obstacles come in a variety of grotesque
forms along the way hulking Giants and
feral dogs ancient Knights and suicidal
monks each enemy is a unique threat and
in groups they grow more dynamic and
more punishing demanding a flexible
approach to combat Dark Souls 3 is also
clever in the way it plays on your false
sense of comfort many deaths come at you
when you underestimate an enemy Hill
dozens of times before the danger is
always lurking it lends an added tension
to the world around you in the long run
survival requires patience
this is true throughout there's a
certain cadence to the combat a certain
pattern to each enemy that's only
discernible when you take a time to
observe it some enemies are weak near
their sword on others are vulnerable
from behind instinct may tell you to
dodge every time a knight retract its
spear but wasting stamina could lead to
a quick death
forcing a restart at the most recent
bonfire Dark Souls 3 doesn't just teach
you new skills it forces you to forget
ones you've already learned the combat
fluctuates between measured duels and
frantic fights but it almost always
manages to keep things fair you may be
outnumbered and underpowered but defeat
is usually your fault
sometimes however Dark Souls three
breaks that rule the camera often
struggles to adjust in tight spaces and
the lock-on mechanic can be capricious
especially against Dark Souls threes
more mobile aggressive enemies in boss
fights that require precision and
emphasize camera becomes all the more of
a hindrance but what impressive
monstrosity these bosses can be in fact
several display more creativity than any
others in developer from software's RPG
lineup these creatures play on your
expectations and force you to adapt one
boss fight pits you against a crowd of
pyromancers that inches toward you
hinting at its weakness with subtle
visual cues intuition tells you to keep
your distance but it soon becomes clear
you'll need to enter the fray it rips
you out of your comfort zone at a
harrowing pace despite the nuance and
novelty of most bosses however some
stick to familiar ground deja boo' kicks
in during several boss fights when the
monsters display movesets similar to
those that came before them diminishing
the creativity displayed elsewhere these
enemies feel recycled it feel repetitive
the skin may be different but the Beast
remains the same
Dark Souls 3 is at its best when it
rewards your progress and test your
characters hard-earned growth these
redundant bosses fly in the face of the
skills you've learned they repeat
patterns you've already mastered they
remind you of a point earlier in your
journey when you weren't nearly as good
as you are now but by and large your
growth is very much respected
it's that thread that near-constant
sense of progress that leads to Dark
Souls three's greatest moments we create
our travelers we make them stronger
faster more resilient turning them into
fighters as we to learn the intricacies
of this foreboding world we can't slay
the final boss until we conquer every
enemy before it so by the end of Dark
Souls 3 we've truly mastered something
that's a special feeling the story here
is more concerned with tone than
exposition but what plot there is tell
the tale of pawns rising from obscurity
the old Lords have abandoned their posts
and in the hunt to usurp them we descend
into those dark valleys and climb those
imposing peaks this is the essence of
Dark Souls 3 periods of doubt followed
by great reward the journey may be rocky
but there's a throne waiting at the end
nameless accursed undead unfit
even to be cinder
and so it is
the - seeketh embers
you
you